[Musique]
quand j'étais petit je rêvais de changer
le monde mais c'était pas compliqué
parce que là d'où je viens
c'est une toute petite île en plein
milieu du pacifique pas très grand
tahiti en polynésie française est
d'ailleurs j'espère que je pourrais
repartir avec anne on aviron après le
tedx après l'antarctique et change et
haïti c'est un peu une histoire de
famille mon grand père que vous voyez
sur la droite sur cette photo était
marin il est originaire de bordeaux
il arrivait en polynésie française là on
construit ma grand mère est restée il a
fait de la politique et il a créé la
sécurité sociale il a permis à tous les
polynésiens d'avoir accès gratuitement
aux soins de santé et ayant grandi dans
cette famille à 16 ans dans l'internet
est arrivé sur l'île avec quelques amis
on a monté le premier blog sur
l'actualité politique et économique de
l'île
tous les jours on aller poster nos idées
sur comment améliorer le quotidien pour
tous les habitants c'était le premier
blog donc le plus regardé par les
décideurs
mais rapidement j'ai été frustré par
deux choses la première c'est que nos
idées étaient lus mais il y avait pas
d'implémentation rien de changé sur
l'île
la deuxième chose qui m'a beaucoup
frustré c'est que plus on analyser les
enjeux du territoire la polynésie
française et plus je me rendais compte
qu'en fait le plus gros problème auquel
ont été confronté
on pouvait pas le résoudre depuis tahiti
le réchauffement climatique vous pouvez
pas faire grand chose sur une petite île
de 220 mille habitants bon je vais
rapidement été rattrapé par la réalité
mes parents m'ont dit avant de penser à
changer le monde le changement
climatique fini tes études
du coup j'ai débarqué à marseille je
vois pourquoi je sais marseille plutôt
que parmi d'autres le soleil pas trop
j'ai fini à luminy et là j'ai continué à
m'intéresser à toutes ces solutions à
ces grands enjeux globaux avec des
professeurs et rapidement je me suis
rendu compte qu'en fait vous pouvez pas
travailler sur le réchauffement
climatique
si vous travaillez pas sur la lutte
contre ta peau
t si vous travaillez pas sur l'accès à
l'éducation les énergies renouvelables
tous ces grands enjeux qu'on connaît
actuellement sont tous reliés les uns
avec les autres
il s'agit pas d'en résoudre un seul et
avec un ami romain que j'ai rencontrés à
l'école on a décidé de partir en tour du
monde pendant nos études pour rencontrer
tous les porteurs de solutions à ces
enjeux globaux qui avait des solutions
locales qui mettait en place dans leur
ville et on s'est dit que si on les
mettait sur internet s'ils ont partagé
leurs innovations on pouvait montrer que
partout sur la planète les gens
construisent des solutions à leur niveau
mais qu'ils peuvent ensemble faire des
solutions globales et du coup on est
parti donc faire ce tour du monde
on comptait les porteurs de projets nous
on est en en faisant ce tour du monde on
avait une idée en tête on s'est dit ah
on va pas juste aller rencontrer les
entrepreneurs et faire des vidéos on va
essayer de monter une plate forme sur
laquelle au fur et à mesure qu'on allait
rencontrer les projets ils allaient
pouvoir poster leurs besoins et on
allait les connecter avec des centaines
de bénévoles à travers le monde qui
souhaitait les aider et c'est là qu'est
née l'idée de make sense
cette plateforme internet pour relier
les bénévoles et les porteurs de
solutions
je donne deux exemples concrets de
projets qui ont été aidés par exemple
par des bénévoles
le premier vous l'avez vu un peu plus
tôt dans la journée avec les écoles de
la deuxième chance
donc c'est une association pour
l'insertion professionnelle des jeunes
et sont juste devant et du coup il ya
deux semaines avec des bénévoles et la
fondation edf les écoles de la deuxième
chance avait un défi
imaginez une plateforme digitale pour
valoriser les compétences des jeunes
pendant leur parcours au sein des écoles
et du coup vous avez des bénévoles qui
pendant une après midi puis un week-end
ont imaginé cette plateforme et
maintenant ils ont récolté 15 mille
euros grâce à la fondation qui leur
permet de développer le premier pilote
dans une des écoles de la deuxième
chance
c'est un exemple l'implication de
citoyens de bénévoles pour faire avancer
un projet le deuxième exemple c'est une
association qui est que j'aime
particulièrement qui s'appelle ciel bleu
ils font des activités physiques
adaptées pour les personnes âgées pour
prévenir plutôt que de guérir il ya
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes âgées chaque année en france
qui participent à ces activités
ciel bleu avait un défi
imaginez une nouvelle ligne d'objets
pour que les personnes âgées puissent
faire des activités physiques plus
simplement et on a huit designers qui
gratuitement bénévolement ont passé
trois mois de leur temps pour imaginer
ses solutions et ont offert une solution
à ciel bleu cd exemple de comment des
citoyens peuvent aider des projets très
concrets mais en fait quand on les met
ensemble on se rend compte que cet
engagement citoyen et bénévole peut
parfois travailler sur des enjeux et des
causes beaucoup plus grande
un des grands problèmes du moment sur
lequel j'imagine que beaucoup d'entre
vous comme moi se sont totalement
impuissants
c'est la crise des réfugiés on entend
parler tous les jours dans les journaux
on se demande qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
sur l'image que vous voyez derrière
c'est une association qui est né à
marseille il s'appelle sos méditerranée
et sos méditerranée avec comme défi de
préparer sa campagne de financement
participatif pour lever plus de 200000
euros pour démarrer les premières
opérations de sauvetage en mer
méditerranée
il ya deux bénévoles un allemand daniel
à berlin et camille à paris qui se sont
mis avec les équipes de make sense et
les équipes de ss méditerranée a
fabriqué la campagne de financement
participatif à mobiliser les gens en
ligne 270000 euros ont été collectés et
elle souhaite méditerranée le bateau que
vous voyez derrière l'aquarius a pu être
mis à l'eau et trois mois après qu'ils
aient démarré les opérations de
sauvetage
les équipes de ss méditerranée avait
déjà secouru plus de 1000 personnes
et ça c'est un des ddd
ils sont toujours en train de lever des
fonds ok n'hésitez pas à les soutenir
parce que vous pouvez laisser faire
toute l'année c'était des gens sont donc
ça c'est un des projets et ensuite on a
eu un bénévole emilien qui s'est dit
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait donc ça c'est
une opération de secours de sauvetage
d'urgence
mais comment on fait quand les réfugiés
arrivent dans les pays d'accueil pour
les pouvoirs les héberger et donc il a
inventé une solution avec une autre
association qui s'appelle singa ils ont
inventé un airbnb pour les réfugiés
qu'ils ont appelé comme à la maison
donc il ya 7000 familles en quelques
semaines en france qui ont dit on est
prêtes à accueillir des réfugiés chez
nous alors que à la même période l'état
disaient qu'ils allaient ouvrir les
portes juste pour 24 mille réfugiés qui
montrent ce qu'ils montrent
l'implication et l'envi d'accueil des
personnes en france donc on a une
solution pour les opérations de secours
il ya une solution pour l'accueil des
personnes dans le pays d'accueil et
ensuite maintenant vous avez des
dizaines de bénévoles et de porteurs de
projets sur la plateforme de make sense
qui travaillent pour les associations ou
les entrepreneurs qui permettent
l'insertion professionnelle soit par la
création d'entreprise soit par
l'insertion sur le marché du travail
pour les personnes réfugiées et on se
rend compte qu'en fait quand on met bout
à bout ces dizaines de projets de
solutions et ses milliers de bénévoles
qui s'engagent au sein de ces projets
vous arrivez à avoir une réponse à cet
enjeu qui semble complètement
surdimensionné là on commence à avoir
des réponses à l'échelle des problèmes
et donc ce qui a démarré comme une
petite idée de mettre en relation des
bénévoles avec des porteurs de solutions
ça a bien grandi ça nous a complètement
dépassé il ya plus de trente mille
bénévoles qui se sont impliqués pour
1200 projets dans 45 pays et c'est
devenu un véritable mouvement
c'est devenu tellement important
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux que
les institutions et les politiques ne
peuvent plus ignorer cet engagement des
citoyens pour améliorer leur quotidien
donc il ya de cela deux ans on s'est
fait contacté par les équipes du
président de la république et du
ministre de la jeunesse pour monter un
programme s'appelle la france s'engage
pour développer l'engagement citoyen et
l'innovation sociale dans tout le pays
et pour nous il s'agit pas de pallier à
l'état ou de travailler en dehors des
grandes entreprises
mais il s'agit de travailler ensemble et
montre que les citoyens peuvent aussi
apporter leur pierre pour résoudre les
problèmes quand on y réfléchit on est la
génération la plus puissante jamais
connecté que l'humanité ait jamais connu
on a des pouvoirs que personne n'avait
auparavant quand vous avez 25 ans et on
a le potentiel de pouvoir résoudre ces
enjeux comme jamais auparavant
il ya aucun des filles qui maintenant
est trop grand pour être résolu et si
moi j'avais envie de m'engager au tout
début c'était d'abord pour mon île
mais quand on prend un peu de recul et
qu'on des zooms on se rend compte que
comme l'a montré en danger tous
peut-être dans le même bateau et surtout
sur la même petite île merci de votre
attention
[Applaudissements]